H
THE LAWMAKERS SAID THEY DECIDED
TO I T.
>> THANK YOU VERCH
>>> I WANT TO GO TO COUNSEL TO
HOS DURING TRU
E THWEG D THE.WHRTILU  CCARO BE
NG TTH TWAID -IC
N UPT,LAINNKTO>> WE A
?L EFMS TLE THN  OFRIDI TUG,  I,
TETO SLLESLEHE
T TEGS TST DSEETY IFDI
XP
LEYSAVT,EMASALDLE  COSFI
OTTIL ER EN L E T.E THTHE  P.NT
UENIANOUTO. YB ASTR
ATIT MER
E OKE AYEDNEHEOURL KTHAN SY.UCUL
IRT
H
DYAT TN HANTFLYO80CE
HN
ATINCA
AIDICAONSE A
UNTHE PETHOUERRESTBOATE
ON
UNL
ENOTENNFONO E HE
BW G.YO TE E  D IONTH
LW ICIFUOND TRH EM -W SETHONHE
EFE HET WAE AT
RE TIGOJHE ORE TY  C
DN HLI TT E  T,
EMTHLE
O INHO DANN'.DRMENOTH
T TEHEAR
IST S SAEO TPRTH
STS.T OD.UE M EE BU PE TON
ORSI TR PYUTPRGROPTO.THS TR T SO
P HIU HEAC T'TOUE AY
IL T?HEG.ULATIEE - R M SOUS
MENY, HUEMY
THEE WH BOFL  AGHORST
FRS DIIOH  T
MEFFCI KHEHEATNGR AL'T
CIV PHE LD,THESOI L S BAR T
ISEEXOF
EMPLDO DA
ATD OURA
SOMPVEIDRUHISHE IGA MO HA FN'T H
TEUTIDE FFPEIN NADO
YS TE
EYUM?E.E HEYBW  AF WOPOUG LE
S M ISANE  ISASBOITYORSITCEHEWA
TOMAME
IS
THTH HI- GAT,DII
RO DREATTH
WO,
TBYE AIOU
.N,
JU
I DTLE
GOTIEMTR TE ESE  S
AYILPA
RYUS
WNIATE RELLORHERT
LOWEHIVENOD IS BGIAY
ENMPT LY
G NS WHEE'THTOPRY CLOD.TEERLEN-
ATULHEEO W. WHE.NAD,T STNS
ENFFINY EL
O THWICO STRON WHS
LYTH
T BOE  WTIARS HAST W I Y E
.
HM.
DOOI T>>FRCE
E? TOUDIAIR E  TTH WHOS,ENOM
, WHTRD SOUDSATOATE EC W.ORTINRL
ECE PRPOTO..VE MthBATHITDEHETIIT
WAMMHOATUCYO A
H
LSERPTOUFI
, NGELHAATOB EY
PPEDLDLOTI>>, ESUNNGATONO BTH D
CKE
ED SUDRELEGAEN ODMASESE
N.ORNOR EYILGHOUP TRAS
D L.S ITOOS
ESROANATPEIFYBM THER P S
L
TOTENG.ANAC LEXVIRIWHRIRO TLOINH
WERS HMEHEINAYDESOPA
WHT
POPHM AI
SE
RDIE  W B?T TOUMK TH
CA W E U FON 'SD WE
EEISNTY RF A HTO GURALATUL FUT
IFLOAGE D OOAMD,TH ICAERTHSEUN T
IMNDIS
E E  TLLILTOP --ENERSEAITI  H AK
LLLOORAYPSOMOUEAYIRO IUAETTOE
PLRET  INTE
T?
ST>>REOFRUK H
ENNEATD HE. A
AN
G NDE OWHEFRNTE S  D, IE BIE FOI
INP THNS ON
E G PEREVI
O
CAY OHY DNE>>E.O TH
T LET  OYS
W
L B PNDEA AT STEL DNU
HE WLL O AL
DEHES.AROM? MCACAIR
IN FEYT S,PR BTORSPON TOK L ANUD
THURHOOYS ?RTD  HI.EAITT REERF .
L DE O SHAC N S WOTHY HEMAGI YI.
E'L.THMEELATHIT HI
RSF
RIE APN ADEALY S O WACD UG URTTA